[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 18
janvier la grande guerre a inspiré une
trentaine d'artistes graveur saint
quentinois
leurs oeuvres sont exposées à la
médiathèque et saint-exupéry à voisins
le bretonneux
le chorégraphe nous et soulier était au
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines au début de la semaine
ce créateur contemporain est une valeur
montante de la danse
nous l'avons rencontrée et 53 ans après
les beatles étaient de retour à
versailles ou presque vendredi dernier
les bouteilles beatles incarner le
groupe mythique sur la scène du cirano
on commence donc avec une exposition et
de gravures jusqu'au 25 février la
médiathèque
antoine de saint-exupéry à voisins le
bretonneux expose les créations d'une
trentaine d'artistes de la thur lidar
gravure de saint quentin en yvelines
ces gravures parle de la guerre la
grande celle de 14-18 et les artistes se
sont inspiré d'un poème écrit par
mérédith le dez est actuellement en
résidence avec les itinéraires poétique
regardez j'écrivais sur la guerre il y a
longtemps
j'écrivais un journal de guerre mérédith
le dez écrit ce texte en 2014 et le lie
à des artisans graveur saint quentinois
qui en débattent et en tire une
exposition ce texte en fait
retrace un peu le ressenti d'un soldat
lors de la de la grande guerre et donc
partage un peu ce désarroi qu'il ressent
notamment en période nocturne par
rapport à ce qui se passe et l'absurdité
de la guerre finalement ça a pris je
dirais quelques mois certaines sont
peut-être plus rapide que d'autres à
réaliser le travail de gravure il faut
savoir que c'est un travail qui est très
lent qui demande mûre réflexion qui
demandent des tâtonnements des essais
pour arriver au résultat souhaité et en
même temps essayer de retranscrire des
émotions
[Musique]
des émotions à lire dans une
cinquantaine de gravure à travers
différentes techniques monotype pointe
sèche aquatinte ou encore linogravure
une violence qu'on essaie de contenir
puisqu'on forcément dans des sentiments
qui peuvent être désagréables
donc certains l'ont ressenti et l'on
retranscrit tel qu'il ressentait
d'autres au contraire se sont un petit
peu je dirais pas ne pas cacher mais on
était pudique dans l'eure dans le
ressenti on fait les choses peut-être
plus abstraites ou des choses je dirais
représentative mais beaucoup plus douce
des oeuvres qui se scrutent une à une
pour comprendre ne serait ce qu'un
instant le quotidien des poilus vendredi
20 janvier le vernissage de cette
exposition se fera en présence de
mérédith le dez l'auteur lira cette
occasion sont pour l accompagner d'une
violoncelliste
toujours au sujet de la grande guerre
mais un autre sujet pour le centenaire
du conflit les archives départementales
proposent aux internautes de retracer le
parcours des soldats tout se fait à
partir de fiches d'incorporation
ça s'appelle adopté un poilu et si vous
voulez y participer il vous suffit de
créer un compte depuis le site internet
des archives qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran passe à la danse maintenant à
seulement 1 29 ans il a déjà créé une
dizaine de pièces chorégraphiques noé
soulier est un chorégraphe en devenir ce
jeune artiste français mail dans chaque
création de la danse classique de la
danse contemporaine mais aussi de la
philosophie
pendant deux jours il était au théâtre
national de saint quentin en yvelines
pour présenter removing nous l'avons
rencontré à cette occasion un sujet
réalisé avec camille lambert et alice
deschamps pour moi ya vraiment un aller
retour entre l'expérimentation
mystique où parfois on va on va on va
être confronté avec des choses qu'on
n'aurait pas pu rencontrer si on était
resté dans la pensée ou s'intéressait
juste d'or d'une réflexion avec ses
pensées ses réflexions noé soulier les
pauses les traduit par le mouvement par
la danse
ce jeune chorégraphe passé par le
conservatoire national de paris est
aussi un passionné de philosophie
je pense que ce qui m'interroge vraiment
c'est c'est l'expérience finalement fins
et il ya plein de choses qui va jamais
mais peut-il fait de trouver un lieu
commun en fait c'est ce qu'est ce qui se
joue dans les gestes
je vais vivre des choses qu'au début
j'ai du mal à formuler articulé après
j'essaie d'être une manière des
particuliers et quand on trouve une aire
de désarticuler alors on se dit on voit
d'autres choses d'autres options
removing sa création 2015 est une
recherche sur le mouvement sur son
vocabulaire des mouvements définie par
un but pratique frappé éviter ou lancer
ça fait un sacré des séquences de
mouvements très très très dynamique qui
engage tout le corps ou qui sont souvent
très explosive et l'idée c'est aussi de
susciter une sensation de mouvement et
des mouvements quand on les regarde
même si on ne bouge pas soi même on va
sentir par par empathie le mouvement et
j'ai l'impression que ça a souvent
affaire cette lan bâti et souvent créés
lorsque le mouvement est incomplet ou
lorsque le mouvement est pas totalement
achevée à tout juste 29 ans noé soulier
est une étoile montante du paysage
chorégraphique ya ceux des love me do
vous aurez bien sûr reconnu les titres
incontournables vote des beatles ils ont
repris vie sur scène grâce aux bootleg
beatles le groupe a incarné le combo
mythique sur les planches du cirano de
versailles vendredi dernier retour sur
ce concert en images camille lambert
sl 1
john paul ringo et djordje l'efap fort
au complet était au cirano de versailles
de vendredi 13 janvier
ou plutôt leurs sosies de boucler
beatles le groupe de reprises à rejouer
le live mythique de 1964 premier concert
de peter en france ou dans cette même
[Musique]
cité au riche les simples ont des mois
pour étudier des vidéos est évidemment
mémoriser la manière dont ils se
conduisaient sur scène la façon de tenir
leurs instruments la façon aussi de
bouger leur tête de parler à leur public
le plus important c'est ensuite de
pratiquer pendant des mois pour un
résultat parfait sur perfect
considéré comme le meilleur trip 2
bennes du combo anglais de bootleg
little a tourné dans le monde entier
depuis sa création en 1978 ce concert
anniversaire était leur premier au
région parisienne le public leur a
réservé un accueil chaleureux
the beatles extraordinaire ils ont
réussi à faire lever tout le monde à
faire danser tout le monde dans le
tyranneau donc exceptionnel avec cette
ambiance là franchement c'est la
première fois qu'on a le feu comme ça au
cirano change
je pense qu'ils étaient très
intelligents dans l'écriture de leurs
chansons et semblait par là une très
large audience et écrivait constamment
de bonnes chansons c'est ça qui a cédé
beatles les beatles de twist and shout
à ticket to ride la hit machine a
conquis les spectateurs versaillais de
bouclettes beatles reviendra en juin
avec une tournée française pour les 50
ans de l'album sergeant pepper
pour cette page cinéma il est question
d'edouard baer du liban et d'un inédit
mais je vous en dis pas plus je vous
laisse écouter lui bloquant dû signer
cet appel en cours un coup de coeur du
ciné cette semaine on pouvait pas y
échapper parce qu'on aime beaucoup
edouard baer ici aussi 17 s'est ouvert
la nuit le nouveau film réalisé par
edouard baer avec lui-même donc et
audrey tautou est aussi michel galabru
dont c'est la dernière apparition à
l'écran alors c'est le comédie
complètement iconoclaste déjanté comme
d'habitude chez edouard baer mais très
sympathique très chaleureuse et ça
raconte en fait que vend un patron de
théâtre à une nuit pour sauver son
théâtre trouver un singe pour le faire
monter sur scène enfin etc etc plein
aventure comme ça donc c'est un film un
petit peu déjanté mais très sympathique
à voir absolument
qui marche pas très bien donc il faut le
soutenir voilà et venez voir n'hésitez
pas je te dis que ton temps normal et
urgent à 13 heures
et puis un petit mot aussi sur les 20
ans du festival télérama dont 20e
édition cette année au ciné 7 est donc
un film à la fiche plus deux coups de
coeur pour cette vingtième année pour ce
20e anniversaire la projection de valse
avec bachir qui absolument un
chef-d'oeuvre du film d'animation qui
font absolument découvrir en salles ça
c'est dimanche à 18h30 et à 17h15 samedi
une très belle avant première d'un film
qui s'appelle par ida blanche qui n'est
donc pas encore sorti et qui raconte en
fait les retrouvailles entre une femme
d'origine maghrébine qui vient retrouver
son mari qui est venu travailler en
france 20 ans
[Musique]
on
vous en avez maintenant la vie
l'habitude avant de nous quitter
quelques rendez vous culturels à ne pas
manquer on commence avec un extrait d'un
spectacle participatif et 7 à la merise
attrape que ça se passe dérive est un
triptyque trois épisodes présentés avec
un rapport particulier au public du
théâtre contemporain à découvrir à
partir de 13 ans dans ce nom c'est le
fait qu en janvier
le wine fille
il veut être mieux qu'ils essayent de
nancy mais bin ans par une âme à pleurer
mais je sentis d'interception alors
j'aime votre pied et jeudi
et c'est encore du côté du prisme ce
sont les chants indigènes qui sont à
l'honneur le musicien français henri
texier joue le samedi 21 janvier
regarder
[Musique]
on reste au prisme le 28 janvier c'est
l'artiste malien salif keita qui sera
sur scène et avec tvq 78,2 vous pouvez
gagner des places pour assister au
concert pour cela rien de plus simple
direction la page facebook de la chaîne
et on regarde tout de suite un extrait
[Musique]
m
non mais
[Musique]
là
on continue avec un rendez vous musique
mais de du classique cette fois les
solistes de lavilledieu propose ce
samedi des options hors de brèches et
enesco et 7 à 18 heures à l'auditorium
de trappes en cinéma lui beaucoup on en
parlait tout à l'heure dans son coup de
coeur à partir d'aujourd'hui 18 janvier
débute le festival télérama
durant une semaine vous pourrez
découvrir à la sélection 2016 de
l'hebdomadaire et sur saint quentin en
yvelines le grenier à sel attrapé de
signer cette d'elancourt propose
plusieurs séances
plus d'informations sur leurs sites
respectifs et on termine avec une native
de l'agglomération sophia aram et samedi
sur la scène du théâtre espace coluche
de plaisir c'est la fin de ce set 8
culture je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis et je vous dis à mercredi
prochain
[Musique]